thank you
thank you
thank you i have to confess
to all of you madam president
board of trustees members faculty
relatives friends
students i have had some conflicted
feelings about accepting
this invitation to deliver
the commencement address to wellesley's
class
of 2004 my initial response of course
was glee
a very strong sense of pleasure
at you know participating personally and
formally
in the rights of an institution with
this
reputation 1245
years of history in women's education
an enviable rostrum of graduates
its commitment sustained
over the years to making a difference
in the world
and its successful resistance to
challenges
that women's colleges have faced
from the beginning and throughout the
years it's an extraordinary record and i
was
delighted to be asked to participate
and return to this campus
but my second response was not
so happy i was very anxious
about having to figure out something to
say
to this particular class at this
particular time because i was really
troubled
by what could
be honestly said
in 2004 to over 500
elegantly educated women
or two relatives and friends who are
relieved
at this moment but hopeful
as well as apprehensive
and to a college faculty
and administration dedicated
to leadership and
knowledgeable about what that entails
well of course i could reassure the
relatives and the friends
just tell them that youth is always
insulting
because it manages generation after
generation
not only to survive and replace us
but to triumph over us completely
and i would remind the faculty and the
administration of what
each knows that the work they do
takes second place to nothing nothing at
all
and that this is theirs is
a first order profession
now of course to the graduates i could
make
reference to things appropriate
to your situation
the future
the past the present
but most of all happiness
regarding the future i would have to
rest my case on
some bromide like
the future is yours for the taking
or that it's whatever you
make of it but the fact is
it is not yours
for the taking
and it is not whatever you make of it
the future is also what other people
make of
it how other people will participate in
it
and impinge on your
experience of it
but i'm not going to talk anymore about
the future because i'm
hesitant to
describe or predict because i'm not even
certain it exists
that is to say i'm not certain that
somehow
perhaps abortioning
a political interest
corporate interests and
military interests will not prevail
and literally annihilate an
inhabitable humane
future
because i don't think we can any longer
rely
on separation of powers free speech
religious tolerance or unchallengeable
civil liberties as a matter of course
that is not while finite
humans in the flux of time
make decisions of infinite
damage not while
finite humans make
infinite claims of virtue
and unassailable power that are beyond
their competence if not their reach
so so no happy talk
about the future maybe the past
offers a better venue
already share an old tradition
of an uncompromisingly intellectual
women's college and
that past and that tradition is
important
to both understand and preserve
it's worthy of reverence
and transmission
you've already learned some strategies
for
appraising the historical
and economical and cultural
past that you have
inherited but in
any honest speech focusing on the
splendor
of the national past
that you are also inheriting
you will detect a faint note of apology
in the descriptions of this be
quest kind of sorrow
that accompanies it because it's not
good enough for you
because the past is already in debt
to the mismanaged present
and besides contrary to what you may
have heard
or learned the past is not done
and it is not over it's still
in process which is
another way of saying that when it's
critiqued analyzed
it yields new information about itself
the past is already changing as it is
being re-examined
as it is being listened to for deeper
resonances
actually it can be more liberating than
any imagined
future if you are willing
to identify its evasions
its distortions its lies
and are willing to unleash its secrets
but again it seemed inappropriate very
inappropriate for me
to delve into a past
for people who are in the process of
making one
forging their own
so i consider just focusing on your
responsibilities as graduates
as graduates of this institution and
citizens of the world
and just tell you once again repeat to
you the admonition
a sort of a wish that you go out and
save the world
that is to suggest to you that with
energy
and right thinking you can certainly
improve
certainly you might even rescue it
now that's a heavy burden to be placed
on one generation
by a member of another generation
because it's a responsibility we ought
to share
not save the world
but simply to love it
meaning don't hurt it
it's already beaten and scoured
and gasping for breath don't
hurt it or enable
others who do and will
know and identify the predators
waving flags made of dollar bills
they will say anything promise anything
do everything to turn the planet
into a casino where only the house cards
can win
little people with finite lives
loved to play games with the infinite
but i thought better of that selecting
your responsibilities for you
if i did that i would assume your
education had been in vain and that you
were incapable
of deciding for yourself what your
responsibilities
should be
so i'm left with the last thing that i
sort of ignored as a topic
happiness
i'm sure you have been told that this is
the best
time of your life
it may be but if it's
true that this is the best time of your
life
if you have already lived or
are now living
at this age the best years
or if the next few turn out to be the
best
then you have my condolences
because you'll want to remain here stuck
in these so-called best years
never maturing wanting only to look
to feel and be the adolescent
that whole industries are devoted
to forcing you to remain
one more flawless article of clothing
one more elaborate toy the truly perfect
diet
the harmless but necessary drug the
almost final elective surgery the
ultimate cosmetic
all designed to maintain hunger
for stasis
while children are being eroticized into
adults
adults are being exoticized
into eternal juvenalia
i know that happiness has been the real
if covert target
of your labors here your choices of
companions
of the profession that you will enter
you'll deserve it
and i want you to gain it everybody
should
but that's all you have on your mind
then you do have my sympathy
and if these are indeed the best
years of your life you do
have my condolences because
there is nothing believe me
more satisfying more
gratifying than true
adulthood the adulthood that is the span
of life
before you the process of becoming one
is not inevitable
its achievement is a difficult beauty
and intensely hard one glory
which commercial forces and cultural
vapidity should not be permitted
to deprive you of
well if i can't talk inspiringly and
hopefully about the future or the past
or the present and your responsibilities
to the present or happiness
you might be wondering why showed up
if things are that dour that tentative
you might ask yourselves what has this
got to do with me
what about my life i didn't ask to be
born
you may say i beg to differ with you
yes you did
in fact you insisted upon it
it's too easy you know too ordinary
too common to not be born
so your presence here on earth is a very
large
part you're doing
so it is up to the self that self
that insisted on life that i want to
speak
now candidly
and tell you the truth that i have not
really been clear-headed
about the world i have described to you
the one you are inheriting all my
ruminations about the future
the past responsibility happiness
were really about my generation
not yours my generation's
profligacy my generation's heedlessness
and denial its frail ego
that required endless drafts of power
juice
and repeated images of weakness in
others in order to prop up
our own illusion of strength
more and more self congratulations
while we sell you more and more games
and images of death as entertainment
it
in short the palm i was reading
wasn't yours it was the splayed
hand of my own generation
and i know no generation has a complete
grip on the imagination and work
of the next one not mine and not your
parents
not if you refuse to let it be so you
don't have to accept
those media labels you need not
settle for any defining category
you don't have to be merely a taxpayer
or red state or a blue state
or consumer or a minority or a majority
of course you're general but you're also
specific
a citizen and a person
and the person you are is like nobody
else on the planet nobody has
the exact memory that you have
what is now known is not all
what you are capable of knowing you are
your own stories
and therefore free to imagine
and experience what it means
to be human without wealth what it feels
like to be human without domination over
others
without reckless arrogance without
fear of others unlike you
without rotating rehearsing and
reinventing the hatreds
you learned in the sandbox
and although you don't have complete
control
over the narrative no author does
i can tell you you could nevertheless
create it although
you will never
fully know or successfully manipulate
the characters who surface or disrupt
your plot you can respect the ones
who do by paying them
close attention and doing them
justice the theme you
choose may change or simply elude you
but being your own story
means you can always choose the tone
it also means that you can invent the
language to say who you are
and how you mean
but then i
am a teller of stories and therefore
an optimist a believer
in the ethical bend of the human heart
a believer in the mind's disgust with
fraud
and its appetite for truth
a believer in the ferocity
of beauty so from my
point of view which is that of a
storyteller
i see your life as
already art full
waiting just
waiting and ready
for you to make it art
thank you
thank you so much tony morrison for your
penetrating and provocative words for
for honoring this class with your
serious message
and for your presence in every meaning
of that word